welcome to private pilot ground lesson
where we're going to be talking about
vfr sectionals and specifically we're
going to be discussing symbols used for
navigation
when it comes to vfr navigation one of
the first symbols that comes to mind
are these little red flags and these are
called vfr checkpoints
and while these are not mandatory to use
these are man-made features that you can
see from the air
that are used by atc as checkpoints to
report your position
or they can also be used as navigational
aids for example
take a look at this vfr checkpoint
labeled signal hill
if i tell air traffic control that i'm
at 4500
directly over signal hill they'll know
exactly where i'm at
and they can use these vfr checkpoints
as well for example
[Music]
cherokee five one two yankee next i want
to draw your attention to these yellow
shaded areas
according to the aeronautical chart
user's guide these are considered
populated areas
but what a lot of people don't realize
is this is what the lights look like in
these areas at night
and when you're flying vfr at night
these are some great landmarks for
identifying your position
now before i move on to some more
important navigational symbols i want to
point out just a couple more things
first is that railroads are often
charted on our vfr sectional
then power lines that are visible from
the air are sometimes charted as well
then you'll also find big highways like
this one depicted on the sectional
all three of these landmarks as well as
when they converge like areas like this
make great visual landmarks for
navigation and landmarks
you can see from the air are the key to
navigation using pilotage and dead
reckoning and if you're wondering what
these are let's talk about that for a
second
pilotage is navigation that is solely
based on identifying landmarks
for example if i look out my left window
and i see these three islands i know
exactly where i'm at
then as long as i keep my eye on these
converging railroad tracks and power
lines
i'll still be able to identify my
position then for my next landmark i
might use the town of mccabe
or if you have really good vision maybe
you can spot this microwave from the air
just kidding i doubt they're talking
about the kitchen appliance the next
type of navigation that we're going to
be using is called dead reckoning
and to use dead reckoning first we
identify a landmark
then we fly specific heading and
airspeed
then after a specific amount of time we
should arrive at our next chosen
landmark and start the process
all over again and we call these
landmarks a longer route of flight
waypoints and we're going to really go
into detail on this when we start our
lessons on navigation
and if you haven't already subscribed
please consider doing that so you don't
miss out on those lessons
one more tool that might help you in
identifying natural landmarks
are these color changes on the vfr
sectional these can help you identify
valleys mountains
and all kinds of other terrain in the
area where you're flying
and to find the altitude changes of this
terrain be sure to flip over to the back
of the vfr sectional where you'll find
this chart
now let's take a look at some of the
symbols used for radio navigation
the first of these is the vor nvor
stands for very high frequency
omnidirectional range
now vors send radio signals all the way
around the station in different
directions
and these radio signals also called
radials can be tuned
in so you can identify your position
from the station
now the next symbol you won't see too
often and that's a tack in
and that stands for tactical air
navigation and these are primarily used
by the military
and while the science behind them is
completely different the way that pilots
use these
is almost identical but the reason i'm
telling you about these is because they
have something called dme
or distance measuring equipment
airplanes that have dme on board can get
their distance from the station in
something called slant range
and this is slightly longer than the
actual ground distance from the station
but you don't need to know all the
details right now i just want you to
have a basic understanding of what dme
is the next symbol we have is a vortec
and that's simply a vor and attack and
combined
and that means it has a traditional vor
that we can use
but it also means that it has dme in
case our airplane has that installed
now sometimes you'll run across this
symbol and this is a symbol for a vor
dme
and this just lets us know that this is
a standard vor that has dme capability
so just like the vortec we can use that
vor and we also have dme
if we need it now let's take a look at
one of these on the vfr sectional
now as i've mentioned before if the
station's on the field you'll see this
little dot right here instead of the
actual symbol
so to figure out what this thing is we
have to look down here at this little
box
and as you can see this one is a vor dme
let's zoom in a little bit on this first
line we have the name of our vor dme
then the second line right here we find
our frequency where we can tune that in
and you'll tune that in on your nav aid
radios just like you would on your com
radios
and this channel you see here is what
you would use to get your dme
if you had that installed on your
airplane and if you wanted to make sure
that you're tuned to the right frequency
you can actually pull up
and listen to your navigate radio for
this morse code identifier this
particular station
uses the letters i i-s-n and to help you
find your bearing from the station
this compass rose is at a 10-mile radius
from the station
and as you can see it's labeled with the
different radials so you can plot your
position on the chart
the last symbol i have for you today is
this little thing that looks like a crop
circle
and this is a symbol for an ndb or
non-directional beacon
now these older stations are slowly
being phased out but the way these work
is that they send a signal out to your
aircraft
that always points directly back to the
station and unfortunately because these
are being phased out
you may never get a chance to use one of
these little gems for navigation
hey thanks again for studying with me
today if you would
please consider subscribing if you
haven't already and be sure to check out
this video or this playlist to get
yourself on the fast track
of becoming a pilot see ya position
you